I'm red it's Friday back on the movie
retrospective and back on the old movies
cuz right you know we did a new one last
time they're not old they're just
vintage yeah yeah yes this is actually
one of my favorite movies from back of
the day when I was a kid Halloween 3
yeah and I didn't know it at the time
but this was like the least popular of
the Halloween series yeah but I'd never
saw one and two I saw this one first
others at first right so and I didn't
know anything about one or two Michael
Myers so I saw this as a standalone
feature which is what it was intended to
be really I thought maybe the other two
were like this it was until later that I
saw when he figured out yeah they didn't
really you know have anything to do with
warning so you saw it without any
preconceived no preconceived notions
just saw it for what it was and I was
you know [ __ ] what you're just come out
again
82 okay so you know I was 12
yeah round that around twelve or so and
it tripped me out and I loved it it
sluggard it's such a weird premise oh
man robots masks step and weaponize
little kids heads and name down
rattlesnakes and crickets and and and
dangerous centipedes and then those go
off to kill the parents I [ __ ] love
it a little bump bump bump bump silver
is almost time it's almost time hey
that's actually I believe that's the
directors voice is it yeah he nailed it
yeah it's like I bought him the they
have you know how that you have some of
those John Carpenter direct his John
Carpenter collection and they have this
really really nice like steelbook yes so
I got him the Halloween through and even
though like I said technically John
Carpenter didn't direct this it doesn't
really matter involved he did the music
he produced and and it is like it is it
is it's a spitting image of a car of a
John Carpenter movie you can't tell that
he didn't direct this it's got it feels
like a to me it feels like a carpenter
flick the soundtrack inviting
the script just the way things are shot
the feel of the movie it just it felt
like a like a carpenter movie to me I
don't care that it really isn't and it
is in that collection yeah because you
know he said he was involved yeah I
think he told the director dude just
like I would do it yeah it was you know
I'm not real sure because after you know
obviously Halloween was very successful
then they rushed Halloween to into
production like very quickly so since
those two were so successful producers
were like well hey we want to do a third
one but John Carpenter and Deborah Hill
said we're not doing a third one unless
Michael Myers isn't in it because we're
sick of doing that it's like our whole
idea which they had actually wanted to
do with the second one but you know the
second one wanted to production so
quickly that they didn't really have
time to you know kind of cobble anything
together they said we wanted to do an
anthology series of films where it's
like one would come out every Halloween
and that was like a different story yeah
like a creep show yeah like a creep show
type thing but you know movies that are
like years apart yeah so this was
supposedly gonna be the first in that
now John Carpenter did not write the
script for this he actually asked Nigel
Kneale who was a very famous British
screenwriter he's very popular very
famous for his Quatermass series which
is like a sci-fi type series is very
very popular over there back in the day
and John Carpenter was a big fan of
those so he asked Nigel Kneale to do it
now Nigel Kneale came up with the whole
you know Celtic paganism type angle like
going back to the roots of Halloween any
element at a Stonehenge it's awesome
the plot is like so convoluted but it's
like you have to love it I mean it's
just like the craziest supervillain
whatever but so the problem the problem
was though that Nigel Kneale script
apparently Dino De Laurentiis who's
their production company was you know
producing it and putting the money they
said oh well it's not gory enough it's
not scary enough so Tommy Lee Wallace
the guy who eventually ended up
directing it who had actually been the
art director on the first two Halloween
movies and was supposed to direct the
second one but actually ended up not
doing it he actually ended up directing
Halloween 3 season of the witch fun fact
he also directed the it miniseries that
came out in 1990 with Tim Curry as penny
wise so you know he
he did some other [ __ ] too I think he
fright night 2 and stuff like that but
um yes so he ended up kind of rewriting
the script Nigel Kneale apparently did
not like the plot that Nigel Kneale came
up with for the screenplay is
essentially the same if they didn't
really change it but so much of it was
changed like more gore was added more
violence was that like a whole bunch
more stuff and Nigel Kneale felt like
well it's not really my script anymore
so he asked that his name be taken off
of it so actually Tommy Lee Wallace I
think has the sole screenwriting credit
on this even though he was just kind of
like you know massaging another because
this is like it's not gory in the same
way as slasher movie is no I mean they
specifically said Nigel Kneale said this
Tommy Lee Wallace said this he's like we
wanted to make it a pod movie and not a
knife movie it had it was gross though
yes yeah remember when that one was used
the guess it was a bobby pin to dig
around inside inside the microchip yeah
silver shamrock label and it blew up and
shot a damn fragment of Stonehenge into
her face and she lived for a little bit
and they show her in the hospital or it
ate a bug came out of her mouth it's
just Zini science yeah you know that
little little particles of Stonehenge
can be weaponized in these little masks
these little labels on a mask that can
be shot into you that would turn your
head into a bunch of crickets and
rattlesnakes and it just don't think too
much well like I said idiot you're like
wow you have to love somebody like a
supervillain with a crazy plan like this
yeah I mean Connell Cochran who is a
warlock
I guess he's supposed to be a warlock
that runs silver shamrock yeah his plan
is like we're gonna take a stone from
Stonehenge one of the big ones yeah
we're gonna transport it over to
California yeah without anyone knowing
we're gonna chip little pieces of it off
we're gonna put each piece in the little
microchips in these masks that we're
making and then when the kids wear the
masks and watch the little commercial or
the thing that signal it'll send out a
signal and make all their heads turn
into like snakes and spiders which will
in turn kill the families
there pear it'll be a big saw one
sacrifice and they do all this with
robots he's got oh yeah I forgot about
that builds humanoid hey Billy androids
yeah just because cuz you can Wyatt you
know yeah if you could do that you would
she has an army of androids and he has a
factory in the factory that he owns the
silver shamrock company is a novelty
company yeah they make novelties and
it's not those kind of novel it's kind
of like what's gonna been out noon it's
like Spencer's gifts that you know in a
way now yeah yeah it's a situation like
that you know costumes and masks and you
supply in places like that it's pretty
cool Flik man I just love that that was
the idea he came up with one yeah cuz he
does he want to kill everyone in the
world I think like the ultimate savage
race and when remember its kind of
unclear really the big picture of his
plan if we're being Ted you're not
supposed to ask those kind of questions
you just supposed to he's a guy and a
young girl all right he looks like he's
about 50 but I'm a kid
yeah sad but dudes back in the 80s and
then you know early 80s and late 70s
they kind of prematurely aged there's a
lot of drinking a lot of smoke and stuff
going on and back in those days a thirty
year old man could look like a 50 year
old and he's hooking up with this hot
young thing he just got divorced and I
think she was single member and it looks
like I'm like like like father and
daughter
it really does that's what looks like
going on you're into that he's taking
advantage you know he's taking advantage
of his of his male position you know I
guess he's a doctor he's like a doctor
right now he's got money and he picks up
this hot young thing they're gonna
investigate this silver she's the
daughter of someone that got killed got
killed and came into the hospital right
and he found and he wanted to figure out
why this guy is seriously like somebody
came in and murdered him yeah and he had
a mask in his hand what his dad his
androids are almost kind of like the
prototype for the terminators there yeah
guys that you know they don't talk much
and they wears business suits and
they'll go and kill somebody they got a
lot of strength
and then they'll destroy themselves one
the one guy he killed that woman's dad
was it with the dad yet I killed the dad
in the hospital and then he goes after
the car douses himself with gasoline
citizen sets himself on fire the car
handy-dandy right in front everybody
else and then the it's a trip because
like the forensic forensic pathologist
is trying to do an autopsy on the body
and he can't find anything he thought
she thought that this were these were
car parts but they were this is a car
part put that together that's not really
the first thing you jump to right like
this guy's like a robot and so they go
to the factory to try to investigate
what's happened and what happened to her
father I kinda can't remember how he got
involved with it he saw the fire right
who the doctor a doctor he saw the he
was in the hospital when when when the
dad came in that's right and that was
like his patient and then he thought it
was weird like if somebody tried to kill
him remember he came in the hospital
said they're gonna kill us all and he
was a doctor assistant and then later
somebody came in and murdered him and
the doctor was like okay I gotta get to
the bottom of that so doctor leaves his
job leaves his wife everything that runs
off this was his ex-wife okay they
didn't make that super clear I guess up
and he runs off with this hot young
thing to go to the silver shamrock
company do it do a private investigation
and it's a it's like he just he totally
blew off with all the surgeries I guess
I got a [ __ ] me to dr. I'm with I'm a
I'm now a private eye I got this hot
chick to bang and I got like you know
can we do [ __ ] I gotta do yeah you guys
take care of that so they get there
there's a little hotel right outside the
factory and they they stay in that hotel
in the beginning their investigation it
turns out like a family shows up there
at the same day and he's been invited to
tour the factory the factory he's a
number one salesman that's been pushing
these products so that's that they make
friends with them and that's how they
got into the silver shamrock factories
by hitching a ride along with this yeah
number one salesman he's kind of like a
old school old school kind of hokey
salesman you know middle-aged carnival
barker type salesman he probably did he
have like a really loud jacket I feel
like yeah you know
even if he didn't like spiritually he
had a jacket on polyester suit big white
tie and all that you know with the two
kids and I think they had a Winnebago
didn't it didn't matter
oh I don't know where they get in this
factory and just strange things were
afoot when they got in there and then
turns out that the guy that owns
affected what was his name again
I don't Katya Cochran Cochran is gonna
use this number-one salesman and his
family is test subjects to test out this
new weapon that he's making it and the
weapon is these three masks it's a witch
a skull and a jack-o'-lantern yeah and
on the back of them they've got this
little metal labels with a shamrock on
the back of it and when you put that on
and they broadcast a certain frequency
through a television commercial like a
little flashy Punk yeah goes boom boom
boom boom boom it's almost time you know
it's kind of stuff and that signal comes
to the television and it will blow your
kid's head up basically and what comes
out as poisonous snakes and insects and
then they kill you and this is uh this
is something good you know this has to
do a salad you know it's a big sacrifice
they're doing it and the thing about
this movie and like I said this is an
old movie so I guess given like kind of
spoil and stuff but the thing about this
movie that even a lot of movies in the
80s didn't do at least in the u.s.
Europeans didn't seem too squeamish
about killing off little kids in horror
movies but the u.s. kind of did yeah ii
love this one yeah this one was dogs
don't kill the kids but like I said
Europeans were just like [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah but uh but this movie I mean this
isn't just killing the one kid cuz like
the one kid whose head gets like snake
eyes and stuff yeah it's pretty much
killing all the kids and the bad guy
wins doesn't he I mean essentially
that's what the yeah that's what the end
was like Tom Atkins like screaming stop
it stop it goes on forever stop it
that's what the movie and the movie ends
with
every single kid who has although that's
that's okay you can't spoil everything
about the movie because there may be
some young people that have never seen
this one but it's something about it
when you're 12 or 13 years old even when
you're in your teens and you're watching
this movie in those days there was
something that kind of drew you into it
it had a creepy ambience to the movie
yeah because I don't know when you're
that age back in those days you you
could kind of you could kind of maybe
imagine something like this could
actually happen and that you know I mean
Stonehenge was involved of course I was
gonna say is that okay this is one movie
okay I know it's called Halloween 3 but
like I said it doesn't have anything to
do with Michael Myers Michael Myers
sentences have anything you pretty much
the only reference that they make like
the music sounds the same kind of they
actually in this universe of this movie
Halloween and Halloween two are
fictional movies because somebody like
you see like a trace of money like
they're playing on TV yeah so those
movies exist and they see universe but
it's not like anything to do with it
yeah
this is one of those movies where you
really I mean the premise like I said
it's like completely ridiculous but you
if you buy into it
it's very very enjoyable don't think
about it just don't think about don't
think about it just roll with it
yeah just roll with which I I don't know
I find that the best way to kind of
approach any movie but like this one is
let's craft because yeah because you
know there you can't really suspend your
disbelief throughout soon although I
have to say this is what I was gonna say
a couple minutes ago was that in a movie
with lifelike Androids pieces of
Stonehenge making kids heads turn into
snakes yeah somehow the thing that I
found the most unbelievable was that
this company would only make three masks
and that every single kid would want one
of them they had a good they had a good
advertisement I guess so that BP BP that
marketing guy and you have
I know it's almost time and now like I
said now everybody that watched is gonna
be stuck in your head lady [ __ ] ever
because like I just bought it for him
for Christmas and we watched it got a
lot of good extras oh yeah it's got a
lot of good extras on the steelbook
edition [ __ ] shout Factory steelbook
it's good yeah I feel like this movie
it made its money back cuz it only cost
like two and a half million to make and
it actually ended up making like fifteen
fourteen fifteen million so it wasn't a
total failure but it was the lowest
performing of all the Halloween movies
and there were a bunch of other you know
big horror behemoths that came out in
1982 obviously poltergeist which kicked
everyone's asked yeah Creepshow Friday
the 13th Part three even did better than
this one like the three day one so it
was not a complete failure but it was
very disappointing and when it first
came out it was almost universally
panned a few critics did kind of liked
it and they liked they're like well you
couldn't really do anything else with
Michael Myers so good for them for like
doing something different so there were
some contemporary you know reviews at
the time that did say that type of thing
but in general most the reviews were
pretty negative but I feel like over the
years it's got a cold father it's kind
of like at because as people become
cognizant that it doesn't have Michael
Myers in it it's kind of like a
standalone in the series so you're not
expecting it I feel like a lot of the
backlash that when it first came out was
because they were expecting it to be a
Michael Myers moving it wasn't should
have been called silver shamrock they
should have just done yeah they probably
probably should have just not called it
that yeah because then you know there's
like six years later they had to like
redcon and go back over return to
Michael Myers part four and was it you
know that this movie could have stood on
its own in its day it did because when
yeah when it hit Cinemax and HBO
kids you know I mean 12 13 14 no kids
just watched it every time he came on
where were you yeah I did you couldn't
go to the club so you just watch Cinemax
yeah your twelfth you just watch that
[ __ ] and we loved it you know we was
loved it well the thing about the
efforts was that we didn't have any
money so we weren't to spend any money
on it yeah so that's that's why they you
know the adults didn't like it but we
like this well like I said I think I
think part of the reason that a lot of
kids might have liked this at the time
cuz I really liked it too I think I saw
it on HBO cinemax like he's in is
because the kids got just in it yeah
they did they were not shy about it like
I said I was like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] that
came it started dying yeah I was like
they did not they did not and he's like
and then at the end like I said and then
the end were they pretty much like
they're pretty much suggesting they're
like yeah we're killing all the children
in the world well at least the ones that
bought those masks I guess if you
dressed up with something else than you
were very the very end you know the
doctors like you know he's getting to
turn off most of the channels you gotta
turn there were only three channels at
the time the last one though they missed
it yeah and the kids were just changing
the channel to go to the other channels
yeah yeah because was I mean was that
the implication that there was it's like
some kind of like weird hypnotic I kind
of feel like that was probably going on
yeah I don't know no they were just they
just wanted to know what the big
announcement was there meant some kind
of surprise it was so kind of some kind
yeah they were gonna like the big
giveaway they were gonna get it and so
you know and they loved the masks I
guess everybody's wearing them all the
kids are trick-or-treating no no yeah
it's pretty cool I like that one scene
where like Tommy Atkins comes see this
is why I'm thinking that the the woman
that was in it that played his ex-wife
will hi there look at this okay just
look at it hi cookie please do not step
on my laptop you can go back there
though that's okay she's behind there
but um the woman that played his ex-wife
and it was the same woman that played
one of the friends in Halloween I can't
I can't remember but she was in it for a
few minutes now like Tom Atkins comes to
the house like he's like hey I got the
kids some masks and they were like this
cheap-ass like plastic ones and the kids
were like lame dad mom already got us
the good ones
yes gonna make our fates make our faces
because I got the impression that he did
not live there is which is why I'm
saying and I was gonna say earlier like
this whole trope of top
I don't know if I call it a troop
because I can only point to two examples
but this movie like Tom Atkins he meets
this the daughter of this murdered guy
and they go on an investigation like
within like ten minutes yes they're
[ __ ] yeah and like I see the fog yeah
and I was gonna say the same thing
happened to the fog he picks up Jamie
Lee Curtis who's like hitchhiking yeah
and thirty years younger than him right
and then like an hour later hour later
hey let's go to my house and have sex
okay yeah and the 80s weren't that good
do you want to get murdered that's
that's how you get murdered I'm just
saying but that was like I don't know if
it happened and what because I know Tom
Atkins was like in a lot of Jamie Lee
Curtis was in the fog because she was
just a friend a carpenter in his bunch
and they just yeah because they just
discuss they said yeah I think what
happened they made that part for her
they did because I mean she had a huge
success with Halloween and I think she
thought she was going to kind of you
know put that into other types of movies
but what she wasn't really getting much
offers except for other horror movies
and she didn't really want to do that so
when he was doing the fog yeah he just
said well I'll just write this part for
you anyway so so that's why it seems a
little bit like she's kind of shoehorned
in but um that noises baby could be
scratching get rather but yeah um I
think that did you anything else you
know I just point it out yeah the rent
this I think they actually uh they
probably a bit on Amazon I think it's on
YouTube also you can stream it yeah it's
a good standalone horror movie from
those days yeah and like I said as long
as you're not expecting attempt Michael
Myers in it were even for it to be a
slasher maybe cuz it's kind of more like
a pagan horror sci-fi yeah lets with
some sci-fi elements and stuff like that
then you should probably and like I said
kind of turn your brain off don't think
too much about no it's plenty star drink
it makes sense the movie does make sense
it does it's just that it's not it's not
scientifically plausible it's not
supposed to be it's about witchcraft
mixed with robotics and technology you
know and it's got this you know it's got
80s technology and gigantic you know
reel-to-reel computers and you
remember that and just not even have a
laptop spat back they look like tan out
on Peters ever liked and number Tandy
didn't have laptops until [ __ ] and they
stole a part of Stonehenge right but one
of the whole stones it was it with the
holes you know since awareness I
remembered all the Stonehenge being in
the warehouse no it wasn't just one
stuff because even like I said they even
did a clever called like at the
beginning in the movie like somebody's
like making breakfast or whatever it is
they're doing and there's like a news
report on about how somebody yeah oh
like stole one of the stuff like how did
take it where did it go and it's done it
that night nobody saw anything no traces
that bond they magicked it I thought oh
gods man yeah I thought the implication
was that yeah they either use robot
because otherwise like how would you how
would you get that through customs oh
you know I'm saying so so that's what I
mean about like don't think about it but
yeah so check out Halloween 3 season 2
which if you have it in silver post
behind but the most beloved in a way
yeah it really seems to be one of those
love it or hate it kind of thing I'm
like I said whether you love it or hate
it depends very much on whether you can
just kind of like roll with its premise
that was the only Halloween I knew I saw
that one I saw that one first like I
said you were lucky because you know
right back to but I was kind of like
where's that dude where the mask
yeah what's a knowing the children right
this is [ __ ] so a lot of our tastes
have to do with expectations I was
reading a thing the other day that
someone somewhere I can't remember where
it was some horror blog or something was
making it a very bold statement that
they thought Halloween through is the
best one of the whole series and people
were like well some people were like
yeah and then some people were like nah
bro what you expect if you were a
slasher with the guy you know have a
Halloween wanted to probably even though
one it was okay actually yeah but
something is a little more sprawling a
bigger story yeah well with more
characters and more stuff happening in
it I would say Halloween 3 and like I
said I'll be pretty menacing like the
other ones no so it's you know I don't
even three is like up the
Videodrome kinda or what else is going
on at that time that I was kind of [ __ ]
man um you know I'm trying to think of
the other things we were Extro and yeah
I know we gotta do one on that day one
of these days it was such a weird ass
movie know where it was it was kind of
being played alongside all that so you
know yeah soon we did had different
expectations I guess you could say you
know yeah and like I said a lot of the
movies back then even if they weren't
objectively very good we still watch
they had some well they had like a kind
of charm to them they were fun you know
what I mean and this is a fun movie I
think so you know yeah your mileage may
vary of course I'm not you know I'm not
gonna say it's better than the original
Halloween but it's not the same not the
same he's not even be the same like
universe or anything like that so I
don't really the two are not comparable
they're not even really the same genre
so I'm not gonna go that far it's like
the fog yeah along that lines a bit
better than the fog actually I like it
better terms of action and things that
they show you and horror and kids heads
blowing up you know always okay you know
what it was like was that it was kind of
like scanners but scanners was a little
more hardcore yeah that's you know we
kind of put it at that level yeah like
yeah it's like a scanners movie scanners
one yeah oh I love scanners one I do too
yeah and that's still like a [ __ ]
popular meme everywhere every time you
tell somebody your mind was blown
everybody put some gif from that
all right so that'll do it for our
little retrospective on Halloween 3
season of the witch check it out if you
haven't already and remember if you like
the show like share subscribe on all
your social media share with all your
friends and family if you'd like to
financially supports chuggin go to our
patreon page patreon.com/lenguin
our movie retrospectives come out every
Friday and our matinee show which is
three new movies in the theater that
comes out
Sunday and our regular episodes come out
every Tuesday so check them out we will
see you next time bye